yeah great to have trevor rogers back
leading natural league rookies and
strikeouts and era he's got seven wins
as well that trails only vladimir
gutierrez
ground ball over to first that's a fair
ball going down the right field line but
again sanchez was shaded that way just
as brinson was shaded toward right
center field
ground ball back toward the middle of
base hit it to center field harper to
second base he'll hold up there
look back at second by trevor now the o2
swinging a foul tip jackson hangs on for
the strikeout to end the inning ranger
suarez who is making his first start
against the marlins this year
maggie smacks one out to center field
way
[Applause]
with a double didn't miss her lead off
home run by much
foul tip and there's a strikeout for
ranger suarez one out
blowing in brenson works the walk
swinging a miss he tied him up and he
gets out of the inning
you're in field swinging bunt they're
going to let it roll and it stays right
on the line
you got to take any way you get them
this ball is cued off the bat and you
would think this is going to roll foul
but it stays right on the line and there
you have it
and that's called strike three
a fastball
two-two to harper swing and a miss got
him with another changeup trevor rogers
boy he's been gone for five weeks but
he's picking up tonight where he left
off at the end of july
now mickey rowe another multi-hit game
for him a double in the first inning and
a single here in the third
ground ball over to third picked up by
there is plenty of time to get aguilar
he could have run it over there himself
struck out his first time
that balls hit well out to left center
field alfaro's going back so is brentson
it is
gone a home run for mccutchen
it sounded good off the bat and he gives
the phils a one-nothing lead his 23rd
home run of the year and it comes here
in the top of the fourth inning
[Applause]
3-2 he takes it and it's just doubted
away for ball four so torey is on and
that'll bring up ranger suarez the
pitcher
that one's lined out to left field
alfaro's on the run it's a fair ball
it kicked up some chalk
one run will score terrius goes to third
it's two nothing phils
ranger suarez picks up an rbi
swinging a miss he missed his spot but
he got a strikeout number five for
suarez
swinging a miss and a change up a
beautiful pitch six k's for suarez
02 pitch coming
got him swinging a miss
ball had a lot of movement on it he has
struck out the side he's matched his
career high in strikeouts and we're only
in the fourth inning
softly left side rojas almost bumped
into diaz and he has no chance to throw
out segura who has an infield hit good
to see trevor rogers back gives up a
couple of runs
four and a third for rogers tonight
singer slider from zach popp and the
right-handers he's going 62 percent
sinker 37 slider
2-2 to jt a swing and a miss he tied him
up ran the sinker in
jackson lifts it to left mccutcheon
going back to the track
looks for the fence makes the catch
he should not take a close pitch here
though
3-2 pitch
outside
not close enough he's waiting waiting
okay now he's gonna go
the 1-2 pitch
lifted in the air out toward right long
run for a harper and he is there he
makes the catch
[Applause]
ball four
barely walks
ground ball
jazz gets to it and feeds miggy on to
first a double play
as naris will take over here in the
bottom of the sixth inning
he got him eight strikeouts for philly's
pitching
swinging a miss
a little high gas
second strikeout for hector
obviously could change the whole
complexion of the game
change up swung out of mist
that's ten strikeouts today for philly's
pitching
i mean there's another change up
a broken bat panic is retired
and ball four jackson walks
a two-out walk third walk of the day for
phil's pitching and here comes diaz who
lined out
and the pitch the runner goes pitches
lifted in the air
shallow left field taraya says he has it
he's under it puts it away and the
inning
is open
3-2 to harper swing and miss bass struck
him out with a slider
bass ready and his 0-2
and it's hit back up the middle off the
back of bass he goes to pick it up the
throw to first not in time
[Applause]
probably scared bass a little bit more
than probably thought it was hit a
little harder and almost hit like a
changeup back to him
strikeout from bass that was a nice
slider down in the way right there to
put mccutchen
he likes the lefties no likey the
righties marlon swing the infield around
against the lefty
and it doesn't even matter anthony bass
with three strikeouts in the eighth
inning but hector nearest a scoreless
inning connor brock in a scoreless
hitting and now it's archie bradley's
turn
and de la cruz out to right harper's
back not going to get there one hops the
wall
and the marlins will bring the tying run
to the plate
now miguel rojas couple of hits tonight
double in the first single in the third
inning
[Applause]
and an rbi
swing at a foul tip got him with a
changeup one out
fastball right down the chute a call
strike three
now brinson tying run at first
lewis brinson runner goes this one is
hit down the right field line toward the
corner and it is gone
a home run for lewis brenson right down
the right field line and the marlins
take the lead
bradley throws a fastball up and out
over the plate and brinson smokes it
right down the line and it hits the the
fair pole
wow
and here's the danger of letting these
guys stay in the game with just the
two-run lead it becomes the same
situation now for dylan floro who was
into his 56th game this season seven of
12
in save opportunities
dede loops it out toward left center
field that's going to drop in for basin
the tying runners aboard for the fills
not going ground ball to third diaz goes
to second for one on the first
that's all they get he slid straight
into the bag and he comes up just a
little bit
and the question is whether or not he
interfered with him after the play
no interference okay
two balls two strikes with a runner at
first and the pitch
swing and a miss and the ball game is
over the phillies lose it three to two
and the marlins have taken the first two
games of this series
out of the pennant race
while the phillies still remain
in the pennant race
[Applause]